[MUSIC PLAYING]
- OK.
So now we're on
to life, sort of.
You'll see that this
actually goes beyond what
you would think of as life.
And then we'll go even farther
beyond that this afternoon.
But instead of me now
chairing this festivity,
you get my colleague,
Immaculata De Vivo,
who will be the discussant
for this section with two
speakers, Wally Fulweiler
and Joel Dudley,
who she'll tell you
about in a second.
But let me just tell you
that I've had a fantastic
time this year with Mack.
The other co-director
of the science program
is Janet Rich Edwards,
who's here somewhere, who's
a Radcliffe Fellow this year.
So we have a special co-director
of the science program.
My colleague and friend,
Immaculata De Vivo.
And when she's not
doing her Radcliffe role
she's actually a professor of
medicine at the medical school
and a professor of epidemiology
at the Chan School.
And she works on
molecular biology,
genetics epidemiology,
biostatistics,
and she's interested
in figuring out
how those things can be
predictive of people's cancer
risk.
But the reason you may
have heard of her work
and seen her on TV is
she's one of those people
who talks about the
Mediterranean diet
all the time.
So over lunch,
which is hopefully
compliant with the
Mediterranean diet--
I don't think we asked her.
You can ask her about that.
But right now I'd like
to turn it over to her,
and Mack's going to tell you
what's going to happen next.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Alyssa.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It is my pleasure to serve
as the interim co-director
for the Life Sciences
here at Radcliffe.
And life is broadly defined
as things which are alive.
And having looked at both
speakers this morning
and last night, and I
said, well, gee, there
is alive stuff in
both of these talks,
especially when Wally,
who as Alyssa showed,
will actually cross
both earth and life.
But I don't want to
take up the time going
through the definition
of what life is.
I want to introduce these
two fabulous speakers, Wally
Fulweiler and Joel Dudley.
And as you know, the
bios are in your pamphlet
so I'm going to do a
very brief introduction.
Wally is, for the most part,
an oceanographer from BU.
She's a professor there.
And her talk will focus on
why the ocean needs you.
And Joel then follow
with his talk.
He's a professor
at the Icahn school
at Mount Sinai in New York.
He will tell us that in his
journey to this presentation
or to this paper
that he published,
he was looking for drugs but
found stupid viruses, quote,
unquote, from The
New York Times.
So it gives me great
pleasure to introduce Wally,
and then Joel will
follow, and we will have
some questions at the very end.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, first I want
to thank the organizers
of this amazing event for the
invitation to speak here today.
For Stuart, for really getting
us off to a fantastic start
and for that beautiful poem.
And for you all, for
the next few minutes,
I'm going to torture you with
my deep love of the ocean,
and I hope that I inspire
you along the way.
So it turns out that I've
been at Boston University an
a PI of my own lab for 10 years.
I know, you can
hardly believe that.
I can hardly believe it myself.
In preparing for
this talk, I began
to think hard about these last
10 years, where we're going,
and where we should be, and what
are the major questions that we
should be addressing.
My lab addresses how coastal
systems are impacted by humans.
To do that, we use ecology
and biogeochemistry.
A terrible word, I know,
but it links and tries
to understand how
biology changes and feeds
on the chemistry and
geology of the environment.
Our goal is to understand
how humans have
changed these coastal systems.
So we work across the
land-ocean continuum,
from forests and rivers to salt
marshes to your favorite bays
and estuaries to the
continental shelf and now
into the deep sea.
If you look at this
slide here, this
is one of the most I
think beautiful slides
of the earth at night.
And you can see
where all the lights
are tends to be
near coastal areas
because 40% of the
human population
lives within 100
kilometers of the coast.
16 out of the 23 mega cities
in the globe are coastal,
so we need people to get
energized and excited and
interested in protecting
these coastal environments
because our humanity
depends upon them.
Over the next few
minutes, I'm going
to walk you through some
different vignettes and ideas
and little bits of I
hope some sort of wisdom
to inspire the next generation.
And to talk to you
about how I see science
happening in the ocean worlds.
But know that I think
these lessons equally apply
to whatever science you do.
So first, behind me you'll
see a submersible named Alvin.
If you don't know the
submersible go Google it.
Not right now but later.
It is a wonderful vessel that
allows scientists to go down
to the bottom of the
sea, thousands of meters
below the surface, to
get a first view of what
is down there.
And it is not just
mud, although you'll
see I'm a deep lover of mud so
it's awesome if it would be.
But there is also wonderful
findings that we will see.
You may have heard
before that we've only
explored 5% of the ocean.
That's insane.
15% of the ocean floor has
been mapped by modern methods,
so the majority of our
ocean is an unknown world
and we need to get on with that.
We need to solve that and
figure out what's down there.
In terms of discoveries,
they're happening left and right
and they are major
discoveries in the ocean.
So for example, just
a few months ago,
brand new deep coral
reefs were found off
the coast of South Carolina.
Reefs we didn't know about.
There are new fish.
This is a hoodwinker sunfish.
It's huge.
It's a brand new species
that was discovered
just a few years ago.
How did we miss that?
Some of the genetic
techniques that we're using
allow us to pull apart
species that would be harder.
For example, genus dogfish
looks a lot like other small dog
fish, but it turns
out genetically
it's vastly different
and a brand new species.
These kinds of discoveries
are the discoveries
that get people's attention.
They're sexy, they're
charismatic megafauna.
Well, maybe not
this deep sea fish
that looks like chewed bubble
gum, but the idea is there.
It's a deep sea fish.
It's exciting.
But these are not the only
parts of science that matter.
Additionally, as
we move forward,
the technologies that
we have are growing,
and these technologies
are allowing
us to see and discover things
that we have not found before.
And the pace of this
discovery is only increasing.
This is a brand new
sequencer called a minion.
If you want to send me a
couple that'd be great.
And this allows you to
sequence genomes in situ.
You can take your sample on
board your research vessel
and sequence it there.
You could do that in the
salt marsh from your car
if you wanted to and
had a big enough car.
So it works.
These are Argo floats.
These are floats that are-- all
of them, almost 4,000 of them,
a global effort to
understand the surface
currents of the ocean.
Each of these floats is
beaming back information
about how fast
currents are flowing,
their salinity, the
temperature of the ocean.
Many of you likely
have a smartwatch.
It's telling you your heartbeat
and your sleeping rhythms.
Well, let's do
this for the ocean.
We're there, we can do this,
and the rhythms in the ocean
are profound.
They don't have a heartbeat,
but we have tidal,
we have ebb and
flow of the tide.
We have huge animal
vertical migrations
moving from the depths during
the day, upwards at night
to feed.
We don't know a lot
about this, and we
need to understand the amount
of organic matter and organisms
that are doing this and the
impact that has on our ocean.
Here I'm showing
you what I think
is a pretty neat diagram that my
PhD student, Emily Chao, made.
And you can see here
that it's showing you
how we can make a smart ocean.
We can outfit human divers.
We can have different
systems on pump profilers.
We can have submersibles
like the Alvin I showed you,
different cable observatory.
These things are happening,
they're coming online,
and we need good minds to
be working on these data.
So whether you're interested in
the science or the engineering
or the computational side
of it, the ocean needs you.
One of my favorite stories
that I'll just quickly
touch on here is this
piece of instrumentation
here is a flow cytometer.
Traditionally it was
used in the medical field
until Penny Chisholm
and her group at MIT
used it to measure phytoplankton
cells in the ocean.
They went to areas of
the ocean that they
thought didn't have a
lot of productivity.
And this was about
30 years ago or so.
They applied flow cytometry
in a brand new way
and they started to measure all
these different phytoplankton.
And then there was this pesky
noise that kept popping up
and they ignored it
because that noise signal
that was coming through
was way too tiny to be anything.
Until they slowly realized
that noise signal seemed
to be changing with things
like salinity and temperature
and perhaps it
wasn't noise at all.
And in fact, it wasn't.
It was this beautiful, little,
tiny green photosynthetic cell.
The tiniest photosynthetic
cell we know
of named prochlorococcus
for little greenberry.
And Penny Chisholm and her group
transformed our understanding
of how the ocean works by taking
new technology and applying it.
And in fact, this is
the harbinger of--
came from, I should
say, the cyanobacteria
that gave us the oxygen
that we enjoy breathing.
And so this tiny, tiny cell,
using a brand new method they
found it and changed how
we understand the ocean.
Lest you believe that you must
have giant discoveries to make
a contribution to science I want
to make a very important point,
and that is that all
discoveries count.
Small discoveries are important.
It is the small discoveries
that allow us to add drop
by drop by drop until we
fill this pool of knowledge
and ignorance, as
Stuart would say,
that allow us to increase our
understanding of the ocean
environment.
It is not every day that
you discover a new species
or find out about a brand new
tiny photosynthetic cell we
didn't know about or get to
dive to the bottom of the ocean
and find deep sea coral reefs.
Those are wonderful,
magical moments
that get lots of attention
on TV and social media,
but they are not the everyday
work and discipline of science.
So it's important to know
that all discoveries count.
I want to tell you a brief story
about when I was a PhD student
and how I learned and
continue to remind myself
how important it is to be
skeptical and challenging
of the work that you
do and others do,
but also to have faith
in the work that you do.
That if you're a
good scientist, you
need to have faith in the work.
So one of the things
that I am deeply in love
with when it comes to
the ocean are sediments.
There really aren't that
many good pictures of them,
so I've made you this
beautiful slide to show you.
Here's our water
column and sediment.
It's oxygenated up
here, and then it's not.
There's no more oxygen when
you get to certain depths
in the sediment.
One of the things
that the sediments do
is they process organic
matter and carbon.
They recycle nutrients for us.
Sometimes they produce
greenhouse gases,
sometimes they
consume them, and they
have one in particular
thing that I'm
interested in is
they have an ability
to remove nitrogen. Now
nitrogen is fundamental to life.
Without it there would
be no you, no me,
no cod, no blue whales.
But like anything, too much
nitrogen leads to problems.
Excess phytoplankton blooms,
harmful algal blooms,
low oxygen conditions.
And where there are humans--
and maybe you remember from
my earlier slide there's
lots of humans in the coast--
then there's more nitrogen,
and that nitrogen then
can degrade ecosystems.
But there's a natural filtering
process called denitrification
that microbes do.
And in coastal ecosystems
and in marine systems,
most of those microbes
live in the sediments.
And what they do is they take
a biologically usable form
of nitrogen, say nitrate
up here, and convert it
to gas, which then can go
up into the water column
and into the atmosphere.
Our atmosphere is
about 70% N2 gas.
It's an inert form.
So the key to
remember is that I was
really interested
in this process
because I wanted to see
how the natural filtering
process and sediments
was removing nitrogen.
And what I expected
to see was that I
would measure N2 gas being
pumped out of the sediments.
Think of the sediments
as exhaling this N2 gas
and I was going to measure this.
And I did it in
the coastal system
in Rhode Island known
as Narragansett Bay.
And I did it there because
the system had been changing
due to changing climate,
and there were some idea
that maybe the nitrogen
removal capacity of this system
was changing and I
wanted to quantify that.
I had this wonderful
historic data
set to build on because
the first measurements
of denitrification in a
marine system were done here.
So I could say,
OK, well, this is
what the denitrification or
the end filtering process
looks like in 1979.
Lots of N removal.
Oh, 1986, we still
have lots of N removal.
And then I came along in 2005
and we still had N removal.
Great.
It was a little less
but it was happening.
This is good.
At this point, I was doing
all of my work measuring
the actual fluxes in a
well-known lab and [INAUDIBLE]
marine biological lab
and Anne Giblin's lab
with Jane Tucker training me.
And so I feel confident
in this because I
was working with the best.
And then I helped my
advisor get funding
for this instrument, the
Cadillac of mass specs in case
you want to know.
If you're interested
in measuring
dissolved gases in sea water
this is the model you want.
Happy to talk to you about it.
So we wrote a
grants and we got--
he wrote the grant and
I wrote part of it--
this part and we
got this mass spec.
And boy, was I excited.
We set up the mass spec, I
go get my sediment cores.
I'm getting out there to
measure the next year.
And I'm like, oh, I'm
going to measure this.
N removal, all this
N gas coming out,
and yes, it's going
to happen, and bam.
This is what I found.
The exact opposite.
Not what I expected.
I thought maybe it
would be the same.
No.
Brought it to my
graduate advisor.
He said, did you
wire it backwards?
Did you run the
samples backwards?
And we methodically went
through all the things.
And I won't tell
you those details,
but just to know that we
didn't wire it backwards.
I didn't run the
samples backwards.
And now what we have seen
is that this system actually
flips back and forth between
removing and turning it
into a gas and actually
making nitrogen.
The bacteria is sucking
nitrogen in from the water
and turning into a biologically
usable form, which has
higher trophic level impacts.
So this I learned--
one other thing
I want to note is
that when I started to
go around to conferences
and give this talk, many
people came up to me and said,
I had these results and I sat
on them because it didn't fit--
and I'm going to use air quotes
and I apologize-- the working
paradigm.
I want to ban working
paradigm from science
because I think it's
squelches ideas and progress.
And so now it turns out that
many ecosystems have seen this
because we begin to slowly
pull this away and realize
that just because it goes
against the working paradigm
doesn't mean it's wrong.
I want to mention
how important it is.
This is the library for the
students in here who don't go.
It's now a criterion
to graduate from my lab
you must go to the library
and send me a picture
of you reading a book in there.
[LAUGHTER]
I deeply worry that we're going
to be losing information that's
not digitized because people
don't go to the library,
but you should go.
It is wonderful.
And you should take time
to read and to write,
which really means rewrite over
and over again because there
is a vast knowledge.
And unless you prepare your
brain for that discovery that
might happen you may miss it.
The prepared brain
is the one that
will be open for
those opportunities,
and there's only
one way to do that.
And that is to sit in a
chair and do the work.
The drudgery a little bit.
The less sexy part of science.
It's also deeply fulfilling.
I want to mention that
persistence is key.
It is vitally important
to know that when
you fail you must
keep going, and that
all of those small discoveries
they build to bigger things
because you are persistent.
So be like the
waves on the shore.
They constantly come.
Sometimes you will work
in a fury of a hurricane
and that is a wonderful feeling.
And sometimes you will
work slowly, ponderously,
and that is fine.
The other big waves will
come, so just be persistent.
We speak often of eureka
moments in science,
and I must tell you I know
of only one in ocean science.
And I have had the fortune of
actually making sure in person
that it was real.
I got to talk to Dr. Colleen
Cavanaugh about this.
The eureka moment
story goes like this.
These are riftia.
They are giant tube worms,
sometimes 6 feet tall,
found at the bottom of the
ocean at hydrothermal vents.
They have no mouth,
no gut, no anus.
When they were discovered nobody
understood how they worked.
There was lots of work
kind of pulling them
apart and looking inside of them
and trying to figure this out.
Dr. Cavanaugh was a first year
graduate student at Harvard.
She sat through numerous
seminars on this.
And sitting in one
of those seminars
that I understand was quite
laboris and long and somewhat
boring, she realized
during that seminar
that the way these
animals work, since they
have no insights to do so, must
be a symbiotic relationship
with bacteria.
The story goes that she
actually shouted this out.
I know what this.
It's symbiotes, symbiotes.
It's sulfide oxidation.
These bacteria can do this.
This is one of the
few eureka moments.
But if you think about it
and you talk with her about
it-- and I hope that you do.
She'll tell the story
better than I do.
You'll learn that she had
done a lot of previous work.
She was broadly
trained in ecology.
She had been working on
microscopic techniques.
She had been thinking about
bacteria and symbiosis,
so the stage was set for
her to make this discovery.
And that goes back a
little bit to this idea
that sitting in the chair
and reading or doing
the work in the lab, they
all build on each other.
Persistence is key.
I want to speak to about
what motivates you.
You need to find it and pursue
it with love and passion
and energy.
These motivate me.
It takes all kinds.
[LAUGHTER]
So these are small plastic
bottles full of ocean water.
These particular set is
from Narragansett Bay.
It's where I grew up.
I grew up on this bay
and I thought I knew it.
I thought I knew all of it.
I can tell you when
the southerly comes in
at lunchtime.
I can tell you where to swim.
I can tell you the ebb
and the flow of the tide.
I can tell you how to
skirt along Dutch Island
and not hit the rocks.
I can tell you the
creepy spot if you
want to go swimming
that I'm pretty
sure there's a big scary animal
down there in this one area.
I went to graduate school
thinking I knew this bay.
And then I started sampling,
and we collected these bottles
to study the nutrients.
So things like nitrogen,
phosphorus, silica.
The fertilizer
for phytoplankton,
for the grass of the sea.
The elements that don't get much
love and yet without them we
would cease to function.
We collected these samples, we
brought them back to the lab,
and all of a sudden
these data came out.
Concentrations of nitrogen,
concentrations of silica,
and with these data
I could tell a story
and see a snapshot of the bay
that no one had seen before.
I could tell you about
life and death of animals.
I could tell you how a warming
climate was changing the bay.
It is these plastic bottles,
this little, tiny plastic
bottle, that transformed
and changed my life.
And at 3:00 in the
morning when I wake up
to think about what's
happening in the ocean,
I often think about the data
or the data that are coming out
of these bottles.
It's super nerdy,
I know, but embrace
that nerd because we need you.
[LAUGHTER]
Finally I want to
say two more things.
I want to say that
you can't do it alone
and you shouldn't do it alone.
And if you get to
a position where
you have found the
thing that inspires you
and you get to work with that
for the rest of your life,
then build a team around
you, the team that you want,
and bring others with you.
Here I am showing you some
of my graduate students.
I want you to note that
they-- and postdocs--
I want you to know
that they are smiling.
They are covered in mud.
They are working
in gross chambers.
This is hours of
filtering, hours.
And that's just the filtering.
That's not the lab analysis
or the data analysis.
They are covered in mud.
They are working on almost
intractable problems.
Not because they
will solve them.
Here's Emily working
on underwater spec
so we can measure the breathing
of the ocean sea floor.
These are happy
students, because they
have found what motivates them.
So find that, get others
to come along with you.
Finally, I want to have a shout
out to people that support us.
And importantly, I want to
tell you one brief thing.
Growing up I have
two older brothers
and I have super
supportive family.
I'm very fortunate for that.
And one thing my mother
would always say to us
is, you could study this
tidal pool your whole life
and never know
everything about it.
And it kind of
became a family joke
where we would say, hey,
mom, so that puddle?
Can I study that my whole life?
Well, it turns out that
she's absolutely right.
That this tidal pool represents
this amazing ecosystem.
There are animals here
dealing with giant waves,
managing to live through waves
hitting them, desiccation
from the noonday sun.
There are neat bacteria
in here, different crabs,
seaweed, mackerel--
so many things.
My point is to tell you, you
need to find your tidal pool.
Go after it because we need you.
The ocean needs you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Fabulous.
That's great.
Just one second, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
Thank you, Wally.
That was great.
And I think this was the
second time that a mom was
invoked to being right.
Let's hear it for
the moms out there.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
That was great.
Lots of questions,
but we're going
to have Joel tell us
about those pesky viruses,
and then we're going to
open it up to questions.
- All right.
All right, thanks
for having me here.
It's great to be
here from New York.
I was getting a little
nervous before my talk,
but I heard during
Wally's talk someone
honking and
screaming at somebody
and it made me feel at home.
So I feel much calmer
now, so it's good.
So I'm going to talk to you
about unmasking thieves.
Thieves of our health
hiding in the shadows
of biological understanding.
Two simple questions really
motivate a lot of my research.
What is health?
What is disease?
I'm going to argue we have
very, very satisfactory answers
to both of these questions.
But first, before
I get into talking
to you about the
research that I do,
I need to sort of orient you
on how I think about the world
and how I approach
biological research.
And that's first by
appreciating there are rarely
smoking guns in human health.
What do I mean by that?
There's rarely the magic
gene, the magic protein,
the magic drug
target that's going
to be the solution
to your problem
if you're studying disease.
What we're dealing with for the
most part is smoking gunships,
and I'll give you a
great example of that.
I have Crohn's disease,
inflammatory bowel disease.
Genetic association
studies have found
over 200 genomic loci
associated with Crohn's disease.
You could loosely think of that
as 200 genes being associated
with inflammatory bowel disease.
By the way, those
200 genes don't yet
explain 50% of the genetics
of that disease at this point,
so who knows, when
things all said and done,
we'll have 400 or 500, 600
genes for that disease.
And where's the drug
target in all of that?
And it really
shouldn't be surprising
that things are so complex when
it comes to disease biology
because humans are layers
of complex networks
all the way down.
Let's just think of a
single cell for a second.
A single cell in the body has
three billion base pairs of DNA
that are wrapped in this
sort of spool and thread
around these chromatin states.
Three billion base pairs
of DNA express some RNAs.
And you might have learned
in high school biology
DNA and RNA are protein, but
that's like the Rutherford
model of the atom, actually.
It's actually DNA to
probably tens of hundreds
of different types of RNAs.
ERNAs, [INAUDIBLE] link RNAs,
the list goes on and on.
We're still discovering
different types of RNA.
Those RNAs go back and bind
to the DNA, regulate DNA.
Then some of those
RNAs create proteins.
Proteins form complexes.
They go back and bind to
the DNA, regulate the DNA.
So just inside one cell we
have these different layers
of networks interacting
with themselves
and across these
different layers.
For example, protein to DNA.
We haven't even left
a single cell yet.
We have a whole constellation
of interactions in a cell.
Cells form tissues.
There's cell to
cell communication.
Tissues from organs.
There's organ-organ
communication.
And if everything
we had in that box
was all we had to worry
about life would be simple,
but the environment
interacts with this system.
So humans are complex
adaptive systems,
which is sort of a well
understood type of system,
at least in how we think
about it in, say, physics
or mathematics.
Complex adaptive systems
have key characteristics
as they evolve over time.
There's interactions
like I just talked about.
The whole's greater than
the sum of the parts,
and here's the key thing.
You can't understand the
system by looking at its parts.
But what do we continually try
to do in biological research
team today?
Is try to understand the
system by looking at its parts,
but we know we can really
do this in a complex system.
Who said this, by the way?
This is an investment banker
in Harvard Business Review.
So for as much grief
as we give the bankers
they have a pretty
good understanding
of complex adaptive systems.
So being a patient
myself has helped me
think of new questions
about disease.
This is a recent trip
to Greenwich Hospital.
Now, I did not put this picture
up here to get sympathy.
Don't feel bad for me
because I'm so loaded
with morphine in this picture.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel 100 times better
there than I do on this stage
right now, so this is not
to get sympathy, trust me.
You just can't tell on my face
because I'm somewhere else.
So one thing that happens when
you get inflammatory bowel
disease is there are
cutaneous-- which
is an autoimmune
disease of the colon.
You get cutaneous manifestations
of disease, erythema nodosum,
and so a lot of skin rashes.
So this happens to
me all the time.
Whenever my disease
becomes active my skin--
I get a rash on my chest.
So I go to the GI
doctor and I say,
isn't this interesting that
my skin reacts when my bowel
disease is about to act up.
And he said, oh,
we know about this.
Of course.
And I said, well, what
do you do about that?
He goes, well, we send
you to the dermatologist.
And I said, well, there's
a connection there.
So I go to the
dermatologist and I say,
well, isn't this interesting.
My skin is connected to my gut.
It's kind of gross but your
gut is kind of your inside skin
if you think about it.
What do we think about the
biological connection here
and what it means to
understand these diseases?
And the dermatologist
says, I specifically
became a dermatologist to never
ever think about the colon.
Please take these steroids
and get out of my office.
So being a patient
made me realize
I was stuck between
these two systems.
So one of the
things we did early
on I did as a result of this
is I took all of the emerging
genomic data that was being
generated-- this was actually
when I was a graduate
student at Stanford--
and we asked the question,
does the molecular taxonomy
of disease look anything
like the symptoms
and anatomy-based
taxonomy of a disease
that we still organize
our health systems are
and our research
institutes around today?
You find, when you look at
the genomic patterns in terms
of diseases and--
I'm sorry, genetics
that are being disrupted
between diseases at
a genome wide scale,
you find, for example,
that at a molecular level,
Alzheimer's disease looks very
similar to actinic keratosis,
which is a skin disease.
Which seems kind of
bizarre until you remember
that the brain and
the skin are together
at one point in a structure
called the neural ectoderm
in development.
So using data to redefine
the landscape of disease,
we can actually
take this concept up
to the patient level.
One of the first things
I did at Mount Sinai
was in getting access to a huge
amount of electronic health
record data, as well as some
records where we have DNA.
I wanted to put into place this
idea of a learning health care
system, which is kind
of a buzzword today.
So what frustrates
me still is when
I go to a health system
they'll say, OK, Joel,
you're a 40 to 45-year-old
Caucasian male, family
history of this,
complaining about this.
Let's treat you
based on guidelines
we know about the situation.
And as a data
person I see, well,
you see millions and millions
of people literally every year,
which patients look like me
and what happened to them.
So when you go to Amazon all
the products that are served up
to you are based on data of
people like you, for example.
So what you're
looking at here is not
a network of diseases now.
You're looking at a
network of patients.
And what I did is I took
all of the quantitative data
we had on every patient--
electronic health
records, heights, weights,
metabolic panels,
CBCs, et cetera--
and I represented
patients by all
the quantitative
information we had on them.
Turns out to be 200 or so.
But I ignored whatever
the diagnosis codes
are given by the physicians.
I considered those
to be subjective.
And then I said,
which patient looks
like that patient looks
like that patient?
I mapped out this sort
of map of patients.
I know from last night there
was an algebraic topologist
in the audience.
I use algebraic topology
to map this out.
So I don't get to
meet one all the time.
But the idea here is this.
So if I'm a new
patient at Mount Sinai,
is my little Waze or Google
Maps dot blinking here,
is it blinking here,
and does it really
matter if I'm here or there?
So what we showed in the
paper, which I don't have time
to go into too many
details, is you definitely
want to be over here.
You don't want to be over here.
I call this
cardiometabolic island.
It's about the nicest name
I could come up with for it.
But the color here is important.
And then after the
patients were organized
by the quantitative
data we said,
where are the patients
with type 2 diabetes
because we have lots of them.
And here in the United
States we are statistically
powered to look at them,
and these red zones
are sort of hotspots of
type 2 diabetic patients.
They're not all in one spot.
Now type 2 diabetes is obviously
this disease we sort of think
as a single disease.
It turns out if you just focus
on the type 2 diabetes patients
alone you get these three
very distinct clusters
of type 2 diabetes patients.
And the provocative idea here
is that we have type 2, type 3,
and type 4 diabetes sitting
under our nose the whole time
but we didn't know it because
we never looked at our patients
in this data driven way.
So you can cluster data all
day long and get cool figures
but who cares if it doesn't
mean anything clinically.
So we had many years of
electronic health record data
on these patients.
And briefly, I can
tell you we showed
that patients in this group--
type 2 diabetes patients--
had increased risk of
heart attack and stroke.
So if you're a diabetic
you have increased risk
of heart attack and stroke.
If you're in this
group you had risk
above and beyond other
type 2 diabetics.
If you're in this group you
had increased risk of cancer.
All diabetics have
increased risk of cancer.
If you're in this
group you had risk
above and beyond the
other type 2 diabetics.
We also have genetics
on these patients.
The genetics was not used
to inform the clustering,
and why this paper was published
in a pretty decent journal was
we did genetic associations
on these subtypes.
And remember, since the genetics
didn't inform the clustering,
it was independent.
And we found genetic markers
that matched the differences
in disease risk that we found.
So that's harder
to explain away.
The fact that the
genetics, which
was independent-- for
example, in this group,
there are genetic markers
that were found in vascular
endothelial signaling pathways.
So again, suggesting that there
are these subtypes and even
markers which we could
start to bin patients into.
So the thing I love about
data driven approaches is it
saves us from what's called
the street light effect.
This kind of cartoon
is a cop is asking,
why are you looking for your
keys under the street light?
And they're saying, that's where
the light is brightest here.
So we didn't coordinate on
this, but I have Donald Rumsfeld
in my slide too.
She goes, I think you said
it a little bit better.
So if there are any
journalists here,
here's the headline I
want to see tomorrow.
Scientists gather at
Radcliffe Institute
to celebrate scientific
legacy of Donald Rumsfeld.
[LAUGHTER]
Because it's coming up.
So please, let's see that
in the paper tomorrow
because clearly that's
what's happening.
I think a more recent
example of where
we applied this
data driven approach
and came to this very
unexpected and shocking result
was in Alzheimer's in which
Immaculata alluded to.
I got one of my favorite quotes
ever in The New York Times.
"I went looking for
drugs, and I found
were these stupid viruses."
So I'm going to go
through how we got
to this unexpected discovery.
So if you're not aware,
Alzheimer's is actually
a very complex disease and
we don't know everything
about the
pathophysiology, etiology.
But for the most
part, we're focused
on-- especially for
drug discovery--
the formation of
these amyloid plaques
and also these tau tangles that
can form inside the neurons.
And for the most part,
drugs have focused
on clearing beta amyloid.
You can actually
do amyloid scans
and you can sort of
see the aggregation
of this amyloid protein in
Alzheimer's disease patients.
So again, the drugs, for
the most part, focused on,
can we get rid of this amyloid?
Since it's a characteristic
pathological finding
of Alzheimer's disease.
Turns out that hasn't
worked very well.
There's effectively a 99.5%
failure rate or something
like that of Alzheimer's drugs.
I mean, we failed
over and over again.
This is the number of compounds
that have failed since 2012
and the number of
trials that had failed.
It would be great to say,
well, since 2012 things have
gotten better.
It stayed exactly the same.
And it's really gotten to
this point of desperation
now where you have
these articles.
Are we wrong about the
theory of Alzheimer's, and is
the leading theory wrong?
In fact, our study,
when it was published,
there's a software tool
that our media folks
use that suggest 800
million people read
about our story in one way or
another through their media.
Which means we're sort
of at the end of our rope
and we're hungry
for something new
in Alzheimer's because
we're kind of out of ideas.
So we leverage the resource
that the National Institutes
of Health had generated.
It's actually a very
forward looking resource.
It's called the Accelerating
Medicines Partnership
for Alzheimer's Disease.
And really, what it is, is
the biggest multiomic study
on Alzheimer's patients ever
really conceived and executed
on.
So you're taking
many, many layers
of complex data collected
from patients, obviously
post-mortem, with controls
and Alzheimer's disease.
Genetics, genomics,
metabolomics--
every ohm you can
think of they're
measuring in this study.
And even [INAUDIBLE] in
clinical data, et cetera.
And we were actually invited
in by a very forward looking
program officer who realized
that most people are going
to be looking at these slices
independently because they're
experts in this
area, and they wanted
to bring in people
that are going
to look across all of these.
There's just not too
many people that do that.
So how do we look
at this type of data
and this holistic modeling
approach is we use something
called graphical modeling.
So if I can get--
so imagine that this
is a genetic marker.
This is a protein.
This is a metabolite.
The other thing might be a
pixel and a brain imaging scan.
And we sort of look at
all these data together
and we see, well, every
time this genetic marker
is varying in the population
this metabolite is going up,
so we'll draw a graphical
connection between these things
and map all these layers of
data in this multi scale network
model.
And then we actually
have tricks to turn
these from pure
correlation networks
into sort of directed networks
using Mandelian randomisation
and things like that, so can
even understand how information
flows from parts of these
multi scale networks
to the other part
of the network.
So the question we were
really trying to ask
was, well, let's not just
focus on beta amyloid, which
is really the predominant theory
in terms of drug targeting.
Let's look at these
very complex networks
that we can construct from all
this multi scale data and look
at the healthy brain network.
Again, genetics, genomics,
proteonomics, et cetera,
and the Alzheimer's network.
And let's just see
how they're rewired.
Let's figure out how
their rewired from healthy
to the disease, and that might
reveal some novel drug targets.
We could target other aspects
of the physiology that's
transforming the healthy brains
into the Alzheimer's brains.
So this is actually a
highly simplistic version
of this software and
the computational steps
that go into doing that.
I'm not going to go through
this, but needless to say it's
actually something that
runs on a supercomputer.
It takes you know
a couple of days
to a week to get the answer.
So we're crunching on the data,
we're crunching on the data.
And really, what came out
was, as we started analyzing
the genes and the networks and
things that were getting most
rewired-- you can think of
it this way between healthy
and Alzheimer's.
A screaming signal
for viral biology.
And we said, oh, crap
because that is not
what we were looking for.
I was looking for
drug targets, I
was looking for
things like GPCRs,
ion channels, and things that
are known to be druggable.
But what we found
is a screaming,
screaming signal
for viral biology.
So we said, well, now we have
to go back and look at this.
And it turns out that
the standard software
for analyzing genomic data,
which actually is created here,
actually throws out viral
sequences by default
because it's often
contamination.
So we had to go back and sort
of rewrite our own software.
So even another person
looking at the same data set
wouldn't have found the viruses.
So what we were able
to do in the end
is pull out these networks where
we can actually see viral gene.
So one of the top viruses we
found directly interacting
in the core networks
that were driving
from healthy to Alzheimer's
pathology were HHV-6, HHV-7.
These actually are a
type of herpes virus
called roseolovirus.
And HSV-1 also had been
implicated in the past
by some folks here
as well at Harvard.
But what's different this time,
instead of find correlations
we can map specific
biological networks
in which these viral
genes were directly
interacting with the host
human genes, such as PSEN1,
which is a very well-known
Alzheimer's gene.
So we get very specific,
testable networks or biological
pathways that can be tested
about how viruses are
contributing to Alzheimer's.
We even discovered a novel
gene, such as this MIR155, which
actually is a viral
response gene,
which we showed in
this animal model
increases beta amyloid
plaques deposition.
So what did we discover?
So we discovered that these
common viral species that
are frequently
found in the brain
can in fact activate
and drive we
believe Alzheimer's pathology.
In particular HHV-6, HHV-7.
And what's really
notable about this
is we actually replicated
this in different cohorts.
So this Amp AD partnership
is they bring in brain banks
from several different
institutions.
We were able to replicate
these viral findings
across independent framings.
If it was just
contamination it probably
would have only been
found in one brain bank.
And we actually identified
specific, testable biological
pathways in which we can
sort of follow on this.
But I actually want to
point out a couple of things
that aren't on here that I'm
really proud about in terms
of what this sort of
unexpected discovery led to,
which is actually related
to the prior talk.
So one thing that
happened was I started
giving talks at
National Institutes
of Health and other places
about this viral finding.
There was a bunch of
intellectually closeted
researchers coming up to
me saying, oh, my God.
I've been sitting
on data for years
that totally supports
this but I've
been too afraid to publish it.
Why?
Because their whole career
is in the Alzheimer's field.
I have ADHD.
I do a bunch of other things.
I could care if they
hated me or not.
So this happened
over-- every time
I gave a talk another researcher
came up and said, oh, my God.
Thank you for paving the
way for me to finally
be able to publish this data
I've been sitting on for years.
Again, it's a huge problem
that I didn't realize
happened in other areas.
Another great thing that
came out of this, of course,
was the fact that there
was a quote from the NIH--
I think [INAUDIBLE] either the
NPR article or The New York
Times article--
where they sort of said-- and
I'm editorializing-- well,
darn it.
I guess we're going to
have to start funding
research in this area
because there's such
an overwhelming amount of data.
In fact, when The New
York Times person said,
they're trying to find
someone to speak negatively
against our article
because that's
what they always try to do.
And they said they found someone
that truly hated everything
about our paper and spent
the entire weekend trying
to find something
terrible to say about it.
But the best compliment
we got was they
said, they dropped the
mic on the data analysis,
and I have nothing
to say on the paper.
And of course, we put
all of this in notables.
We put all of the data
and all of our software.
All of our code is in the public
domain for anyone to reproduce.
So when we give talks about
these scientific findings,
a lot of people think,
well, how does it
relate to me, for
example, as someone
sitting in the audience?
So if you're interested
in Alzheimer's, there's
all kinds of cool
stuff that we're
following up on such
as using anti-virals
to treat Alzheimer's
disease and a bunch
of new potential druggable
pathways we've identified.
But I want to point
out something else
we're doing to really take the
spirit of what we did in terms
of analyzing the
Alzheimer's data,
and taking this data driven
approach to illuminate what we
don't know about
health and disease,
down to the individual
patient level and the way
that you could
personally experience.
So we have this project at
Mount Sinai called Lab 100.
So the practice of medicine--
I mean, talk about not
embracing the undiscovered.
Practice of medicine
I would argue
is among the worst at
this, either by trying
to mitigate the undiscovered
or pretend that it just
doesn't exist.
Particularly by
evidence-based medicine.
So they like to focus on
Of course, a lot
of this evidence
is based on small studies
of a couple of hundred
if not 1,000 people.
And we really try to mitigate
discovering incidental findings
and things that
are totally unknown
and trying to find
ways to deal with it.
So what we're building
is this new type
of clinic at Mount
Sinai, that's actually
going to open the door
soon, to really embrace
the undiscovered and as part
of routine medical care.
And we're asking the
question, what if you actually
had a health record?
We always talk about
electronic health records
but we don't have
health records.
We have records of your
diseases and your treatments.
Health is currently defined
as absence of everything
we agree is a disease.
You think about that
for a long time that's
pretty embarrassing.
I mean, that's our
definition of health.
So if we had an
electronic health record,
what would we measure?
We measure all these different
aspects of your health.
I'll give you a sneak peek at
what this actually looks like.
This is when you actually
start in the clinic
and you have your initial
consult with your doctor.
And we do everything you're not
supposed to do in medical care.
We measure thousands and
millions of things about you
and every aspect of your
health when you're not
complaining about a disease.
I mean, that's enough
to give a physician who
went through the standard
training a heart attack.
And there's good
reasons for that,
but data can deal with
incidental findings.
And this is what it looks like.
And I'm not going to show you
the in between because then I
ran out of time, but
this is what it looks
like at the end of your visit.
We do a whole 360, highly
data driven, millions of data
point view of your
overall health.
We have a conversation
with you about it
and we give you access to
this and you own this data.
So we're actually
building clinics
that embrace the unexpected
about each one of you
because there's so much we
don't know about health,
about wellness, about
vitality, and resilience.
And that's waiting
to be discovered
in each and every one of you.
So thank you.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, I'm going to
talk [INAUDIBLE]..
Well, that was great.
Thank you, Joel, and of
course thank you, Wally.
So I'm going to
just, if you will,
start the questioning
because I actually
have a lot of questions
related to both talks.
And then we'll open
it up to the audience.
I'm going to start with Wiley.
So I'm going to go with
the glass is half full.
So we don't know much
about oceans, right?
And can we say that's
partly driven by the fact
that we didn't have the
technology, the instrumentation
to actually go looking for this?
And I was provoked
to ask that question,
given that beautiful green
little thing that you showed
by your MIT colleagues
so that we wouldn't
have been able to find that.
So it's sort of like one
of these questions where--
and it also applies
to Joel somewhat
is that sure, we don't know
what we're not looking for,
but a lot of it is driven by
what we can actually look for.
And there is a Rumsfeld
quote that I want to use,
given that Rumsfeld is playing
such a prominent role today,
which is you cannot go to
war with what you want.
You go with what you have.
And I know I mangled
it completely
but sort of the spirit
is there, and it sort of
relates to these questions
that both for you and for Joel.
But Wally, you can go first.
- Sure, sure.
So I would say to Rumsfeld
you probably shouldn't
go to war then, but sorry.
- Just a quote.
- No politics.
- Sorry, no politics.
- Just couldn't
resist that quote.
- So I think that for sure
our technology is increasing
at this really rapid rate.
I mean, Alvin's been
around for a while now,
but it just got a major
retrofit to go to deeper depths.
Please don't ask me which depth
because I currently forget.
But I do think our
technology is really
increasing at a
fantastic rate, and I
think this is a wonderful time
to get into science in general
and into ocean science.
And I think it's
really important too
because, for example, the
finding of those coral
reefs off the Amazon
or off the Carolinas.
We have ideas about trying to
do things like deep sea mining
or drilling for
oil, and we may be
making decisions or fishing--
we might be making decisions
without fully understanding
the environment that
we're going to impact.
And since we so rely on these
environments for the well-being
of humanity, I think it's not
only important that we're using
this technology to explore
but it's actually--
it's not life and death but
it's vital to humanity to do so.
- I'd like to capitalize on
that because in the short term
it doesn't look
like life and death,
but oceans are critical for
climate and just sustainability
in general.
So I think that
maybe there should
be some sense of
urgency with respect
to also ocean discovery.
- There is absolutely
a huge sense
of urgency, and if you don't
feel that you should because--
yes, absolutely.
- Because the oceans
look so pretty
and they sort of have this
sense of, well, it's beautiful.
What could be lying underneath?
And we know also from the
[INAUDIBLE] visits and other
oceanographers that have
come through Radcliffe,
there's a lot that would--
to say that there's
a lot we don't know
is completely underestimating
what we really don't know.
- That's true.
- So Joel, I had
a question for you
with respect to the big data
aspects of all the discoveries
because I myself dabble
a little bit in big data
from a cancer perspective.
And even when we look at data
that was generated by TCGA,
which is the Tumor Genome Atlas.
Where in my own
disease that I studied
it was treated as this
composite disease.
And, oh, my goodness.
People were shocked that when
we looked at the molecular--
we looked under the
hood, so to speak.
The molecular subtyping
said, oh, my goodness.
This is at least four
different diseases.
Now I wasn't shocked
by that because
at the time, you go with what
you have, which is histology.
So increasingly, we're finding
out more and more with respect
to every type of disease.
The four types of diabetes.
There's at least four or five
types of endometrial cancer.
There are five types of ovarian.
And I'm sure, as you start
binning these diseases,
not just by their genetics
and their genomic profiles,
and you start adding in
lifestyle an environment, which
we're going to get
increasingly-- not
just from the medical records
but we already have in hand
from many of these studies.
My point is, we're
going to be so ahead
of these brilliant physicians
whose job is really,
to be fair to the physicians,
is to blunt the bleeding.
It's really to just take
care of the problem at hand.
So I'm not surprised
that your dermatologist
and your G.I.
Doctors were working
in silos because they're so
trained to that's their job.
You have a G.I problem
you work on the G.I.
You don't think about the
inflammatory immune response.
So it's not just a statement.
The question is, we have
all-- because this also
plagues what I do.
We have all this
data, and you showed
some brilliant networking.
How do we translate
that to the clinic,
especially in light of the
fact that Mount Sinai also
has this 360 lab.
What do you tell the
patient or this person who
comes in and says, well,
we found x, y, and z
but there's really
not much we can
do because therapeutics
or the treatment
hasn't gotten there yet.
I'm sorry that was so long.
- I'll try to be brief.
That's a big, big question.
I think one is to try to--
the health system
itself is not set up
to support this type of thing.
So what we're trying
to do with Lab 100
is to rebuild the
whole system so it
can support this type of thing.
And one to bring the science
of precision medicine
to precision health and
wellness because pre disease.
It's a lot easier to prevent
a lot of these diseases.
I think the physicians will be
open as long as you equip them
with the tools to act
on the information
and act on the information
at the right time
because they're busy.
I'll give you an example.
We've known that there are
certain genetic markers,
pharmacogenomics, that
should influence prescribing
of medications.
And we actually have
50,000 of our patients
that are sequenced, and the
existing electronic health
record software can't even
connect a genetic marker
of the patient to the time
when the drug is prescribed
and alert the physician.
We actually had to spend
$4 million at Mount Sinai
to build our own
software to do that.
There's a last mile
problem of connecting
what's known to the
clinician but in a way that
is at the right time and
context of giving patient care,
and that's a big challenge.
- Right.
And I think that's
the infrastructure.
It's sort of like we need to
build this infrastructure.
- And I'll just
add very briefly.
There's going to be
some things we're never
going to get that
require evidence on,
so I think we also
need to empower
patients more to collect
evidence on their own.
So I'll give you an example.
With my Crohn's disease I asked
my physician, what should I
or shouldn't I eat?
And he'll tell you, you
eat wherever you want.
That's insane.
Well, there's never been a
randomized controlled trial
on all these foods to
tell me what you should
and shouldn't eat in Crohn's.
And so you're saying, I
can drink beer and donuts
or have a salad, and from
the perspective of medicine
it's the same thing
for my disease?
It's insane.
So one of the things
we're doing is
building a N-of-One
clinical trial software
so patients can start running
rigorous clinical trials
on themselves and
collect evidence
on these lifestyle things.
[APPLAUSE]
- So I'm going to
be a little bit
of devil's advocate on that.
So that would assume
that the patient actually
knows the implications
of their findings?
- Oh, yeah.
So the hardest part about
building that software
was not the statistical
engine that calculates it.
It was the user experience.
- Right
- Getting someone to understand
a p-value and an effect size.
We probably spent a year
on that part of it alone.
- Easily.
That was super hard.
And I'm not claiming
that we figured it out
but that's super hard.
- Yeah, I think that's a
general concern that I have is
that when we construct
these algorithms
and predictive scores,
we are assuming
that the general population
understands what risk is.
And that's not to
undermine the intelligence
of the general population,
but I have colleagues
that don't understand what a
p-value of 0.05 and they're
brilliant.
So I guess it's
sort of a process.
We're in a situation where we
have to educate low, high and--
The gradient as well as, as
I like to say, we need not
only the--
maybe we don't need the
depth but we certainly
need the breadth to understand
a lot of this big data output.
- Absolutely.
- OK.
So I think at this point
we should open it up
to the audience because
I can stay here all day
and talk to these
wonderful people.
There's a microphone
that's coming.
I would ask that when
you ask your question
please pose it in a question.
And please state your name.
Big group.
- Hi, I'm Jo [INAUDIBLE],,
and I'm a sleep researcher.
So this question is for Joel.
We know both diabetes and
Alzheimer's have relationships
to disordered or
insufficient sleep.
I wondered if your islands
included sleep anywhere
in this evaluation.
We know the brain has
no lymphocytes system,
but during sleep
the toxins do drain.
We don't sleep the
toxins don't drain.
So what do you think?
- So we don't currently have
that data on the patients.
We're actually conducting a
study using wearable sensors
and things like that to measure
sleep and incorporate this.
And yes, the circadian
effects we know are huge.
Not only in influencing
the metabolic system
and the immune
system, and we simply
don't have that data yet on
a large scale population.
But we need it badly.
- Yeah, big piece.
Thank you.
- Hi, Sally
[? Seaver. ?] Another
sort of general
question, and that is,
those of us who got the early
polio vaccine before about 1973
also got SV40.
And I heard a really
fantastic seminar,
probably in the late
70s, from Germany
where they track all cancers.
And they could start
to see if there
was any difference
between people before who
got the early polio vaccine
versus the other one
on various cancers.
And one of the things
they were hinting at
is there might have been
some stuff on some brain type
cancers.
Have you heard any updates
or looked at your data
with those of us who
have gotten SV40?
- I do believe SV40 showed
up, and I can't recall off
the top of my head,
but of course,
the evidence of the relationship
between viruses and cancers
is growing day by day.
I'll note that
one of the genomic
features we found that
related to the viral activity
in Alzheimer's are these things
called G4, quadruplex domains.
But the only important
thing to note
is that those are actually being
targeted by cancer therapies
right now because
there is virally driven
cancers that target those.
And we're actually looking at
reusing those in Alzheimer's as
well.
- Thank you.
- Christine [? Borgman. ?] We
study data sharing and reuse
in the sciences, and we
have found in oceanography,
biomedicine, astronomy, and
elsewhere that one person's
signal is somebody else's
noise and they often
don't agree on what are the
data in the first place.
So many of the effects
you're talking about
disappeared at
those early stages
when they threw
away the outliers
and did the data compression?
How do we think about
this better as far as
how much are
methodological issues we
should be trained for?
How much are statistical?
How much are just the
equipment, like you said,
that you pick the data up?
Or even the software that threw
away those signals because they
thought they were noise?
- That's a huge question.
So I think for sure there's
some standardization
of oceanographic
methods, and I'm
sure this applies
to other fields
too that we could
get board with.
And people are beginning to do
that, and that is wonderful.
So I totally support
those efforts.
And then, I think we
need to get better
at having people
embrace that noise
and not get rid of
outliers, like you said.
We're super trained
to be risk adverse
and yet we know, just from
sitting here this morning,
that that's a bad idea.
Those outliers have a
lot of power to them.
And we also need to start
embracing negative results
because if we're
not publishing those
then we just repeat those same
experiment over and over again.
So it's a big issue I
think we need to deal with.
- I'll just add very briefly.
One of the things that
the accelerating medicines
partnership for Alzheimer's
did is the program officer
required that the
rawest form of all data
was put into the public
data sharing repository.
Because the genomic
data, the imaging data,
they go through several
steps of transformation.
So that was a very
prescient move on her part.
Not being a data
scientist, she knew
it would be super important to
get the rawest form possible
because of this.
- Thank you.
- Hi, [? Ned Bacon. ?]
Joel, I want to ask you.
Have you any thoughts
about the increases--
maybe there isn't any increase.
The susceptibility to these
viral effects with aging?
- Yeah, definitely.
I think the ultimate
story of the viruses
and Alzheimer's are two things.
One is that innate immune
activation is bad in the brain
and around inflammation,
which we've kind of known.
And in fact, the genetic
association studies
for Alzheimer's over
the past couple of years
have pulled up a lot of
immune markers focusing
on this immune cell in the
brain called the microglia where
the neurologists
are kind of like,
why are all of these
immune signals coming up
in the [INAUDIBLE]?
This is weird.
What do we do with this?
But the other side of that
is then immune senescence,
which could be explaining why--
[INAUDIBLE] aging of
the immune system,
why are these viruses
becoming active in the brain
at a certain stage of life?
There's potentially a
role for immune senescence
in the activation of
these viruses as well,
but it's still pretty early.
Early days.
- Hi, great talks.
Janet [? Rich ?] [? Edwards. ?]
I'm an epidemiologist,
and one of the things my team
has been studying is trying
to bust open the silos of
the way we think about bodily
systems.
So we correlate the
reproductive system
with the cardiovascular system
and find some new connections
there.
You mentioned the way the NIH
is organized by bodily system.
I suspect we're going to
look back on this and say,
this is such an archaic, quaint
way of thinking about the body.
That there really
aren't such systems.
I was intrigued that you
mentioned at least one instance
of them encouraging you
to go across the omics
and wonder if you have
any comments about how
that silo busting perspective
can be encouraged perhaps
revolutionarily
across all of NIH.
And I don't know if
NSF has similar issues.
- NIH is a big, complex place.
Obviously, I think,
again, the folks
in the National
Institutes of Aging
are very forward thinking.
In fact, what they often do is
they put me on study sections
and they say, go cause trouble.
[INAUDIBLE] actually the
program officer quietly
says to go cause trouble.
And the evidence is just
mounting more and more.
So we actually have
a paper under review
right now where we do this
sort of network analysis
across all tissues in
the body in looking
at diabetes and autoimmune
disease and Alzheimer's and all
these diseases that
have co-morbidities.
And you can actually find
this one master connector
in monocytes that
actually connects
all these different things.
So I think it's just
a matter of time.
- Hi.
Wonderful talks.
My name is Robin [? Barns. ?]
I'm a retired primary care
physician.
And we don't just
staunch the bleeding.
Actually--
- I knew I was going
to offend many people,
but I'm on limited time here.
- That brings me to a big
speculative question that
may or may not be answerable.
So part of what's
important about medicine
or about primary care,
which is longitudinal
and you have chronic
relationships
with patients whose diseases
come and go and so forth.
How does what you're
doing interact with that?
And the bigger question
is, how is this
going to change the health
care system as a whole, which
is not just medical?
Just a couple of thoughts.
- That's a big question.
- Well, that's what--
- What's that?
- That was basically the
big question that I asked.
It's just huge.
- Yeah, it's huge.
I think the way to
do it, unfortunately,
is to sort of restructure the
health system fundamentally,
and that's actually--
so I'm at Mount Sinai,
but I don't want
to spend too much time on this.
But that clinic you saw, by the
way, the way we designed it?
It can be built in a
week and a half actually.
And actually, we have a smaller
version of it that's a kiosk.
So our mission is to create a
parallel pulley decentralized
health system that can be
deployed closer to where people
live that then puts major
pressure on the existing health
system to change.
So that's my goal.
I tell Mount Sinai my job is
to shut their primary care down
with my new model.
- Colleen Cavanaugh.
I follow these questions in
terms of how revolutionary
your approach has been that it
could be applied to the earth
more broadly and from
nations to the whole earth.
And I wanted to
ask how you think
you can do this and do it fast?
And I have one answer from our
microbial sciences initiative
symposium with Jim Collins.
- I think this is your question.
- No, no.
It's both.
- How to heal the ocean.
How do we head the ocean?
- This is an NSF
proposal and NIH.
- Well, I'm actually
quite excited to see
what you're doing and
wonder if we can do
a similar thing for the oceans.
Because we often talk about
ecosystem health and we
have no definition for that.
And we have no [INAUDIBLE]
we just go look for problems
and that's what we
get excited about.
But trying to understand
that difference
between health and
disease, basically,
of an ocean basin or an estuary.
I think we have
data to start to do
that but we need these
computational tools
and to apply those.
- Yeah, my brain
goes immediately
to microbiome research, which
maps very well in the gut
microbiome because
it is an ecosystem.
And there's this
dream that people
have that if I can just
find the healthy microbes
and then give people the
healthy microbe it'll
make them healthy, but it turns
out that it's a big ecosystem.
It's a big garden you've got
to kind of prune and seed
and stuff like that.
And I think that's going to be--
what my talk said.
There's not going to be a
magic bullet [INAUDIBLE]
it's ecosystem approach.
- But what I'm looking for is
the bullet for the funding.
- The bullet for the funding.
- --do it fast.
And I can tell you, Jim
Collins, who figures out
some medical problem, solves it
in the lab, and in two months
it's translated.
His answer was he starts
a lot of companies,
makes a lot of money,
and that money does it.
There is another big
funding groups like the name
Gates [INAUDIBLE].
This has to happen, and
quickly, for me in particular.
- So what we are seeing is that
people make a lot of my in tech
and they are deploying
resources because they
understand what we're trying
to do and they are funding.
- But who wouldn't
understand it?
- You'd be surprised.
- I'm not going to name names.
[LAUGHTER]
- Don't name any names.
Smart.
Yes?
- Dr. Fulweiler-- oh, sorry.
My name is Joshua [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a textbook editor and
I have celiac disease,
so I'm very interested in
the micro biome doctor.
Dr. Fulweiler spoke to us about
finding passion and building
teams.
I'm an amateur astronomer, so I
think about amateur scientists
and amateur number
crunchers and people who
do it for the love who
may not have had it happen
in their life to be able
to do it for a living
or to have a more conventional
institutional involvement
in science.
So the question I wanted
to ask each of our speakers
in the present session is, are
there opportunities for citizen
science, for amateur
participation for joining
a community of people who do
anything from spit in a vial
or take a cup of seawater
for you to actually help you
with the sense making.
- So there are absolutely
groups for citizen science,
and I think you've hit
on something that's
really fundamentally important.
And that is that scientists
only see sometimes
the things that they're going.
And they're maybe just
going for research queues
for a few weeks, or I'm going
down there to study one bay
and I'm there infrequently.
There are groups that
are out in the water,
like fishermen, all
the time, and there
are groups now that are
working specifically
with people that are on
the water, for example,
or are surfing or kayaking
or whatever it is.
There's lots of groups
to join for that,
and I'm happy to
give you examples
offline if you would like
but there's watershed groups.
And for sure, I think
that citizen science
can provide a whole new
set of eyes and knowledge
that we're missing, as well
as I think you're probably
going to allude to in a
second, this idea of being
able to capture data and provide
it to scientists to sort of do
the analysis on.
- So the trend we
have here, of course,
is that powerful measurement
technologies [INAUDIBLE] become
rapidly commoditized
and distributed out
into the consumer realm.
Genomic sequencing is
falling precipitously.
It's easy for anyone
with a credit card,
basically, to start
sequencing something
or bring your minion
onto the boat.
And wearable sensors are
increasing in fidelity.
And you may not be
aware, of course, that--
You ever heard of
Apple Research Kit?
Apple has a software
built into iOS
to conduct distributed
clinical trials, which
isn't quite citizen
science yet because you
need an academic
institution to partner with.
So it's happening.
And I want to point
out, there's someone
at Mount Sinai named
Jason [INAUDIBLE] who
has this Resilience Project,
which is a citizen science
project to get people to submit
biological data to find out
if they're resilient to
diseases, for example.
Could we find someone who
has ApoE4 at the age of 80
and is cognitively intact?
- My name is [? Ricardo ?]
[? Cortez, a ?] retired
chemical engineer.
I have two questions.
One is on the slide that you
show nitrogen removal that
changes through time.
Was that because the data that
was in the early ages of data
collection was wrong or
because of climate crisis
has changed the
chemistry of the ocean
and basically reversed the path?
And the second question is,
if the idea of a viral species
is the causation of
Alzheimer's disease,
and virus multiplies
so fast, why
is the Alzheimer's disease
so slow to develop?
- So those early data for
the N were not incorrect,
and I'm happy again to
talk about this offline.
It's a little bit
of a long story.
But basically, the
climate warming
that we've seen
in coastal systems
is changing them in ways that
we would not have expected,
and that is what's been driving
the switch that I showed you.
- I'd say on the viral side.
Again, there is no cause of
Alzheimer's, just causes.
[INAUDIBLE] Alzheimer's that
will come together [INAUDIBLE]
really complex way.
So what I didn't know
about these viruses, which
is important to note, is
that there are retroviruses,
meaning that they can
integrate into the host DNA.
So what we think
is likely happening
is that these in
fact-- so the exposure
can become very early in life
and that these viruses are
lying in wait in the genome
of the neuron, basically,
and they're becoming
activated later in life.
Why they're becoming activated
we're not totally clear,
actually.
- I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm just a science enthusiast.
But my question
is kind of related
to his on the global
warming in the coastlines,
but mostly about
the coast heights.
And I'm sure you're busy
enough trying to figure out
what's going on at this moment,
but are there studies like
if new sediments-- like if
suddenly there's a new tidal
flats, new sediment, does that--
how that differs than the
older sediment [INAUDIBLE]??
In history, it's hard
to tell coastline
is buried under water.
But anyway, that's
what my question is.
- So I think what you're getting
at is this idea of trying
to understand, potentially,
how nitrogen removal capacity
changes in sediments over time?
And there's some really neat
ecological theory on this,
but basically what you tend to
see is really early sediments.
You see nitrogen fixation.
So that arrow going
down, basically.
The sediment's making nitrogen.
The bacteria in the sediment
is making nitrogen. And then,
as you build up organic matter
or food for the bacteria
that will switch
and you'll start to
remove the nitrogen.
And there, of course,
are caveats to that,
but that's the general trend.
- I think that was
our last question,
and there were many questions.
A testament to how great
both lectures were.
And I'd like everyone to please
applaud both Wally and Joel.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, I would like to
thank Mack and Wally and Joel
for just carrying us to
what is almost lunch in such
a beautiful way.
And so let me just say one more
thing before we let you go.
Actually, a few more things.
The first one that I
forgot to say before
is there is a Twitter
stream for this.
It's hashtag the undiscovered.
And there's a lot
going on there so you
can recap what you already heard
and you can go contribute there
also.
Now there is lunch.
And I mentioned earlier that
there is a poster session.
And this poster
session is dedicated
to ideas about how
we can incorporate
the kind of thinking that
you see today in the talks
into K-12 education and
education at other levels.
And I just wanted to
show you because Stewart
showed a draft version of
something just like this.
One of the posters,
which I admit
to having something
to do with, is
about how Isaac Newton got
the information and the ideas
that he needed going all the
way back to ancient Mesopotamia.
And if I just let this
scroll across the screen,
you'll see that is
not the neat arc.
And that is the
cleaned up version.
And if I just show
you that again, I
want to point out at
the left those three
circles you can't read?
One says a step toward
Newton if it's green.
The one at the bottom says
wrong or unhelpful ideas.
Failures I suppose
we should call them.
And the one in the middle
is the most important
that says partial credit.
So Stewart pointed out early
on that nothing is ever
totally right, and all of the
brilliant work that you heard
here is not totally right.
It's mostly right
and it's helpful.
And so the idea is, how do we
communicate this complexity
without giving people
the idea that scientists
don't know what they're doing?
So that's the point.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]